MIRE TEBOW REUNIONS AS THE
SPRINGBOARD FOR TODAY'S
REUNIONS IN THE NFL, WE WOULD
TO SEE TRIVIA QUESTION FOR
BOTH OF US. CHRIS, I DON'T
KNOW THE ANSWER AND I HAVE A
FEELING I MAY NOT KNOW. I
AFTER I READ IT. YEAH THERE
HAVE BEEN FIVE PLAYERS TO
PLAY IN THE NFL. NOT PLAY FOR
AT LEAST EIGHT STRAIGHT
SEASONS THAN PLAY IN THE NFL
AGAIN. CAN YOU NAME
SOMETHING THAT HAPPENED, LIKE,
BYRON WIZARD, WHITE HORSE. I
I MEAN ALDON SMITH DID THAT
GO THAT LONG? NO, NO RIGHT?
NO. I KNOW. HOLD THAT. DON'T
GIVE US ANSWERS YET. I MEAN
THE FIRST THING WHEN I THINK
OF LONG. SO I THINK A DICK
VERMEIL BUT OF COURSE, HE'S
NOT A PLAYER. I REALLY HAVE A
HARD TIME. T WAS NOT A PLAYER.
THANK YOU. BUT I'M JUST
SAYING LIKE WHAT WHO WE
MISSING. THERE'S ONE PRETTY
RECENT MATT FAIRLY
MAN. I CAN'T THINK OF
EVERYBODY SITTING, YOU KNOW,
I'M THIS IS ONE OF THOSE
WHERE THIS IS ONE OF THOSE
IS THAT YOU? YOU JUST
FEEL LIKE YOU FREAK OUT LIKE
I CAN'T, I CAN'T PROCESS IT.
I SHOULD KNOW THIS. I SHOULD
KNOW THIS. I SHOULD KNOW THIS.
I SHOULD KNOW. I'M JUST THE
ANSWER DOESN'T POP THROW AND
AND JODY NOT, YOU ARE CRAZY.
YOU KNOW PRODUCERS TELLING ME
I WORKED WITH THE GUY BEFORE
AND HE SAYS BOTH OF US HAVE
WHAT, WHAT IS HE TALKING
ABOUT? IS OUT OF THE NFL, FOR,
AT LEAST EIGHT STRAIGHT
OUT OF THE NFL THERE, HAVE
BEEN FIVE YEARS OF PLAY. A
PLAY IN THE NFL. NOT PLAY FOR
AT LEAST STRAIGHT SEASON
EIGHTS, AND THEN, PLAY EIGHT
STRAIGHT SEASONS AND PLAY IN
THE NFL AGAIN. I DON'T GET IT.
I GIVE UP. WHO IS IT? WHO IS
IT? TELL AKANE, I'LL GO.
I WAS UP TO, CAN WE GET THE
NAMES? OH, DOUG, FLUTIE
WEDDING. DAMN IT. HOW DID I
FORGET THAT? BUT YOU KNOW
WHAT, I DIDN'T REALIZE IT WAS
THAT LONG? EIGHT STRAIGHT
SEASONS. WOW. DOUG FLUTIE.
DAVID DIAZ IN.
PONTE.
TONY ADAMS, ROSS, NAGLE AND
FRANK TIGER WALTON. WELL, WHO
CAN FORGET FRANK TIGER WALTON?
I WAS, I WAS THINKING OF I
WAS THINKING OF FRANK LYON
WALTON WASN'T THINKING OF
FRANK TIGER WALTON DOUG. I
WAS TAUGHT TO THAT QUESTION
THOUGH, BECAUSE HE STILL
PLAYED, THAT WAS A TOUGH.
IT'S NOT LIKE HE STEPPED AWAY
FROM FOOTBALL TOGETHER. OKAY?
TOM BRADY, TIM TEBOW, SLIGHT
COULD HAVE GONE TO THE CFL
FIRST PICK SINCE WE WERE BOTH.
ALL RIGHT, THANKS. OKAY. YOU
KNOW WHAT? I WANT TO SEE BILL
BELICHICK, GO BACK TO THE
GIANTS. THAT'S WHAT I WANT TO
SEE IF YOU WANT ME. ASK ME
ONE REUNIONS. THAT'S THE
NUMBER ONE THING ON MY LIST.
WOULD LOVE THAT. OF COURSE,
GIANTS ARE MY FAVORITE TEAM.
I'M A HUGE FAN OF BILL
BELICHICK, AND OF COURSE,
BOSTON NEW YORK RIVALRY
RIVALRY IS VERY REAL. SO I
WOULD HAVE ALWAYS LIKED TO
HAVE SEEN THAT, YOU KNOW,
THERE WAS ALWAYS THOSE
RUMBLINGS. AND REMEMBER, LIKE,
BACK FOR FIVE YEARS AGO,
WHERE THERE WAS LIKE,
BLINGS THAT MAYBE BALICHEK
WAS THINKING ABOUT THE GIANTS
AND THINGS LIKE THAT. I DON'T
KNOW HOW REAL THEY WERE BUT I
WOULD HAVE LOVED TO HAVE SEEN
IT. GARY MYERS WAS PUSHING
THAT A FEW YEARS AGO THE THE
YEAR AFTER THE JIMMY
GAROPPOLO TRADE AND THE
REPORT CAME OUT THERE WAS
RICE AND SETH WORKERS FROM
HAD ALL THAT AND MORE
RECENTLY WORKERS FROM
SUGGESTED THAT IT WAS THE
GIANTS AND A COUPLE OF OTHER
TEAMS THE BELCHECK WAS
TALKING TO BUT BELCHECK WAS
ALWAYS UNDER CONTRACT WITH
THE PATRIOTS THAT WAS NEVER
GOING TO HAPPEN, IT WAS NEVER
GOING ANYWHERE AND IT WAS
EXPLAINED TO ME AT THE TIME.
VERY
HE SIMPLY IT'S GOING TO TAKE
HIM FIVE YEARS TO GET ANY
OTHER TEAM TO WHERE HE HAS
THE PATRIOT, RIGHT? AND HE
DOESN'T WANT TO WASTE FIVE
YEARS. YEAH. SPINNING. HIS
WHEELS TRYING TO GET ANOTHER
TEAM TO THE POINT WHERE THE
PATRIOTS CURRENTLY ARE. SO
HE'S JUST NOT LEAVING. HE'S
HE'S NOT OKAY WELL I LOOK
I GO BELICHICK AND TOM BRADY
JUST I MEAN IF I WANT IF I
WANT A TRUE REUNIONS IF I
WANT TO HAVE A COUPLE OF
PERSONALITIES GET TOGETHER
AGAIN, MEN THEIR FENCES. I
BILL BELICHICK AND TOM BRADY,
END UP TOGETHER. AGAIN, ON
THE GIANT SAND ON THE GIANTS.
OKAY. YEAH. LET'S DO THE JOB
ASS THE TEAM. THE TEAM THAT
HAS BEEN THE THORN AND TOM
TEAM THAT HAS BEEN THE THORN
AND TOM BRADY SIDE. THE TEAM
THAT TOOK AWAY HIS UNDEFEATED
SEASON FOR WHICH HE
SUPPOSEDLY WOULD GIVE UP TO
SUPER BOWL RINGS IF HE COULD
HAVE THAT PERFECT SEASON AND
SOMETHING ELSE HE SAID ON THE
DRAFT OF TOWN, A COUPLE OF
WEEKS AGO YES BELICHICK AND
BRADY ON THE GIANTS. ALL
RIGHT EUROPE. ALL RIGHT.
WHOO, I GOT SOME GOOD ONES
HERE. I'M REALLY NOT SURE,
YOU KNOW, LISTEN FOR
THEATRICS AND EVERYTHING LIKE
IT THE WAY IT ENDED, I WOULD
BACK WITH THE STEELERS AND
MIKE TOMLIN AND BIG BEN. I
MEAN, COME ON, YOU KNOW, THAT
UP THERE ALL THOSE
PERSONALITIES, YOU KNOW JUST
TO SEE HOW THEY WOULD REACT
WITH THAT, HOW THAT WOULD
ACTUALLY END UP WORKING OUT
AND EVERYTHING LIKE THAT. I
MEAN FROM THAT STANDPOINT,
CAN'T MISS TV
WITH
I GREW UP THERE AND I WOULD
BE INTERESTED TO SEE IF BIG
BEN AND A BE COULD STRIKE UP
THE THE SAME CHEMISTRY, THEY
HAD AND HOW THAT WOULD GO AND
IF IT WOULD GET SMOOTH OVER
AND EVERYTHING LIKE THAT. SO
THAT'S ONE THAT THAT WAS THE
FIRST ONE THAT POPPED IN MY
BRAIN. HONESTLY, WHEN I WHEN
I HEARD ABOUT THIS DRAFT,
YOU KNOW, IT'S AMAZING HOW
QUICKLY YOU FORGET THE
THINGS YOU DID LAST WEEK BUT
AS WE WERE GETTING READY TO
INTERVIEW JUJU SMITH,
SCHUSTER LAST MONDAY. THERE
WAS SOME SORT OF TECHNICAL
THING AS WE'RE GETTING IT ALL
THREADED AND I MADE AN
ANTONIO BROWN CRACK. AND I
I DON'T THINK EITHER HE
DIDN'T HEAR
IT OR YOU DIDN'T CONVENIENTLY
IGNORED IT. ALL RIGHT
, HOW ABOUT MIKE MCCARTHY AND
AARON RAWLEY
EVERYBODY. SO WHO CARES?
BETTER THE DEVIL? YOU KNOW
THE DEVIL? YOU DON'T KNOW AT
SOME POINT MCCARTHY AND
ROGERS WHO WOULDN'T THAT BE
GREAT NOT THAT IT'S GOING TO
BE THE COWBOYS BUT MAYBE
MAYBE WHAT HAPPENS IS ROGERS
ENDS UP WITH THE 49ERS
MCCARTHY GETS FIRED BY THE
AND HE GETS HIRED TO BE THE
OFFENSIVE COORDINATOR.
NADER IN SAN FRANCISCO. THE
AS IN 2005, BOOM, THAT WOULD
BE YEAH THAT WOULD BE AMAZING.
SHANAHAN COACHING THEM
MCCARTHY THE OSI AND ROGERS
THE QUARTERBACK. I'D LIKE
THAT. THAT WOULD BE, THAT
BE AWESOME TO SEE CERTAINLY I
DIDN'T THINK ABOUT THAT ONE
EITHER. I'M MAD. I ACTUALLY
DIDN'T THINK ABOUT. THAT WAS
A VERY GOOD ONE BY YOU. I GOT
A FEW GOOD ONES HERE. I DON'T
CARE IF YOU STEAL HIM AT THE
END. I MEAN, I DO THINK ABOUT,
I'D LIKE TO SEE MARCUS
PETERS WITH THE RAMS AGAIN
AND HIM AND JALEN RAMSEY ON
THE SAME TEAM. OH, BJ TO THE
GIANTS, THE RAIDERS TO
OAKLAND, RIGHT?
RIGHT. BUT HERE'S ONE AND I
CHEATED A LITTLE PETE, DEM, A
LITTLE LITTLE LIGHT OF LIGHT.
A LIGHT HAS GAVE ME THIS ONE.
ALL RIGHT, I'M GONNA I'M NOT
GONNA LIE HERE. THE OILERS
UNIFORMS, I'D LIKE TO SEE
THEY CAN WEAR THEM AS TON SO
THROWBACKS, RIGHT? I MEAN,
THE TENNESSEE TITANS HAVE,
THEY'RE HOLDING THEM HOSTAGE
BECAUSE I BELIEVE THEY STILL
OWN THE RIGHTS TO THOSE UNIS
AND EVERYTHING ABOUT IT. BUT
COME ON THAT'S PART OF
HOUSTON. THEY DON'T DRILL FOR
OIL AND TENNESSEE. LET THE
TEXANS HAVE IT BACK.
SO THEY CAN WEAR IT FOR A
THROWBACK EVERY NOW AND THEN
THEY PROBABLY DO DRILL FOR
OIL AT THE SCENE. HEY TO
I BET THAT IS A REVIEW, YOU
KNOW, I LIKE IT. WHEN YOU SAY
I'VE GOT A LOT OF GOOD ONES
YOUR RATTLE OFF THREE OR
FOUR THAT ARE VERY AND I TAKE
THE WORST ONE. THAT'S YOUR
HAMMER IS ONE THAT YOU DIDN'T
EVEN COME UP WITH. I'LL GO
I'LL GO AND LOOK AT THOSE
TECH OF THAT. THERE'S THIS
EARL GOING TO RUN OVER THE
GUY HERE. ISAIAH ROBERT.
OUT, WATCH OUT ISAIAH. IT'S
MY CALMING GOD.
WONDER WHERE THE REMNANTS OF
THAT JERSEY ARE TODAY. WHERE
IS THE REMNANTS OF THAT GUY'S
CHEST? I WAS THINKING THE
OTHER DAY. YEAH, WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE RAMS. THE
FIRST FOOTBALL HELMET I EVER
HAD WAS THIS CHEAP LITTLE
BLUE HELMET FROM SEARS WITH
HORNS THAT DIDN'T COMPLETELY
FINISH. SO IT WASN'T A
COPYRIGHT INFRINGEMENT THAT
THINGS IN A LANDFILL
SOMEWHERE. I MEAN IT DOESN'T
DEGRADE. LIKE, WHERE IS THAT
THING NOW, I EVER THINK
ABOUT THAT. I KNOW STUFF END
UP.
YOU'RE RIGHT. IF YOU LIKE ONE
OF THE GREAT SPORTS RELICS OF
ALL TIME, I MEAN THAT WOULD
BE ONE THAT PEOPLE WOULD BID
BIG MONEY FOR. ALL RIGHT, I
GOT ONE MORE PICK TO MAKE. WE
GOT TO TAKE A BREAK, SO I
EXTRA TIME TO THINK ABOUT IT
SO IT CAN BE BETTER THAN
CHRIS HAS MORE PFT LIVE RIGHT
AFTER THIS.
ALL RIGHT, I GOT ONE MORE
PICK. FOR OUR DRAFT OF THE
REUNIONS. WE'D LIKE TO SEE
THIS ONE GOES WAY BACK. THIS
GOES BACK. 27 YEARS. . WOW,
COME ON. JERRY JONES. COME
JIMMY JOHNSON. HA HA HA. THAT
WOULD BE GREAT TOGETHER AGAIN.
BRING HIM BACK. HOW BOUT
THEM COWBOYS? HAVEN'T WON A
SUPER BOWL SINCE JIMMY WAS
THERE? COME ON MEN, FENCES,
BREAK BREAD, SING KUMBAYA. AND
WE'VE ALREADY FIRED MIKE
MCCARTHY. SO THE COWBOYS NEED
A COACH BRING BACK TO JIMMY
JOHNSON. I LIKE FIRST
OFF. IS HE IN THE RING OF
HONOR YET? HAVE THEY HAVE
FISHED THERE? HAVEN'T EVEN
DONE THAT YET, RIGHT? I DON'T
THINK IT DOES. NO, I MEAN,
THAT'S AMAZING. THAT'S JUST
SHOWS YOU HOW BITTER IT IS
THERE. BUT I KNOW THAT WAS,
HEY, MAN. THAT WAS MUST WATCH
TV, THE COWBOYS OF JIMMIE
JOHNSON AND JERRY. JONES IS
AMAZING FIVE SEASONS TOGETHER.
YEAH, THEY WON TWO, SUPER
BOWLS, THEY PUT TOGETHER.
THEY'RE A TEAM THAT WON
ANOTHER ONE AFTER JOHNSON WAS
GONE. I MEAN, COME ON PEOPLE.
LIFE'S TOO SHORT. I MEAN,
SERIOUSLY JUST THE GENERAL
OBSERVATION ANYONE OUT THERE,
FIND A WAY TO GET ALONG WITH
PEOPLE. YOU THINK DID GREAT
THINGS TOGETHER. HOW COULD
THAT HAVE HAPPENED CRYING? I
DON'T KNOW. I REALLY DON'T.